what's bizarre in a way about American
politics over the last generation is
that people's economic self-interests
have become detached from their
political
views and they're much more concerned
about these kinds of cultural questions
than they are you know if if they were
really worried about losing their jobs
and losing their social standing they
should be all in favor of Obamacare
because then they won't lose their
health insurance as well but they're all
voting against Obamacare and they've
been persuaded to because really the
politics has become sort of tribalized
where even if your team is doing things
that hurt your economic self-interest
you're going to keep you know you're
going to keep rooting for it because
you've been convinced that the other
side is evil that's what political
scientists refer to as effective
polarization where you're not just
disagreeing over policy issues you
actually hate the other side and think
that their winning is going to mean
you're losing